how's it going as my spirit pack wearing
glasses [ __ ] welcome back to the forest
so what the [ __ ] is that a leaf how
young welcome back our there's a seat oh
hello little beautiful creature yo ty oh
oh that [ __ ] died good this will be my
house decorations
alright so apparently the map is
randomized so that would they flock now
for some reason they more never Jerry
the death of Jerry now what
get off my house you [ __ ] the AI in
this game needs a little a bit of work I
would think because I don't think this
is the place you oh I better get in the
water hurry hurry hurry all right so we
spawn in a pretty cooler place right now
get it because it's worried so that's
pretty awesome the game is buggy as [ __ ]
I think we can establish that but as
they at least fulfilled all their
promises and I think this game seems
promising so alright
snack bar says he's full a skull some a
jaw some chocolate bar a magazine about
a yard on a sailing boat at the club for
more seagulls to kill if I was this guy
I'd obviously stay inside the damn boat
I wouldn't stay in a damn shelter that's
me they really fluff around me like what
that stop and see who approved the
seagull AI were you how high were you
seriously alright well we now have went
on a little walk I haven't seen any
cannibals yet either
on this map which is good because it was
[ __ ] red like I spawn in the middle
of their [ __ ] camp or some [ __ ] I
don't I don't know what that was all
about but they had a lot of lizards and
I miss Larry the lizard let's set up a
proper fire pit right I feel like we
should have a fire pit
almost had everything already so let's
let's finish that [ __ ] up one stone yes
so all the bushes kind of look like
people and if you can tell if you look
in the distance it looks like people are
looking at you it makes me a little
paranoid but I like it
alright we got what we needed actually
we're so bad as that surviving we have
this seagull twerking and god that's
creepy man place we had there my friends
we have Tyler the Creator just [ __ ]
tweeted me holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
are you serious that's so cool well [ __ ]
Siegel died get off my tab Siegel's an
awesome Jesus Christ I'm fangirling oh
but but that [ __ ] is [ __ ] popping my
t-shirts we can build boat you could
build traps you could build a table
right I saw a furniture you can't build
furniture yet though this is fantastic
cause it is like minecraft but actually
fun plus seagulls get off my path who
the [ __ ] coded these yeah
can I at least cook them or some [ __ ]
like hey stay off my logs you [ __ ]
this is take a while maybe I should
gather some food instead
I need 80 [ __ ] two of them but this
could be like a work in progress
is that a dead guy [ __ ] is it mermaid
the hell are you come from what the [ __ ]
did I kill him where the treat was he up
in the tree or someshit
what oh god I can eat him
awesome I have a skull is this a skull
well at least I have a means of defend
myself all right
food it's gonna be an issue soon if you
don't take care of it so let's find some
[ __ ] food I know they can [ __ ]
attack me at any point now and I ain't
trusting that [ __ ]
I'm so hungry before this place was
crawling with wildlife not like not what
happened
hey this is good drugs lots of the drugs
well this is awesome it looks even
prettier and I don't trust it though yes
oh god what the [ __ ]
get your [ __ ] axe out you [ __ ] you
don't have time for this where oh god oh
god I'm hungry I'm sorry what the [ __ ]
is out there something is coming for me
you [ __ ] cannibal [ __ ] how about
here oh god it's terrifying they're not
even scary but it's like you you want to
live and it makes me what hard rock hard
oh I'm did something what did i do
exactly oh ho okay well I made a hammer
that's awesome okay so I I quit the game
and it didn't save for some [ __ ]
reason this game is really buggy and
that's very frustrating to play but I
still want to play more so what the [ __ ]
are you gonna do about it I think this
time we should focus more on getting a
lot of food so I want to get a storage
or some [ __ ] and have that [ __ ] [ __ ]
ready
they're just cannibals over there
they're literally next to my turf get
the [ __ ] away from my turf cannibals
I just wanted to build a log holder it's
that too much to [ __ ] ask they have a
flashlight I should probably kill one of
them so that's right I chopped your
friend to pieces I'm gonna beat him with
his [ __ ] skull they're so sneaky I
don't like it let's just run away from
them I don't like them a turtle eternal
oh you're so cute dye your dinner oh god
no actually never mind fight for me
turtle fight for me it's are you dying
you did you scrub oh god they're
attacking now they know my
vulnerabilities [ __ ] they keep
[ __ ] following me I'm gonna have to
kill them I'm gonna build an axe or some
[ __ ] and then kill them fight to me in
real life oh god oh god they're coming
from the trees oh god they're famous
samurai Ram a dam a dam Oh God
fight me fight me fight me oh oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] he got me with one hit that's
[ __ ] the Wow
I can still crawl though bark if my
house is over there Sal oh here we go
I never found this
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you I made it out ah
survival of the fittest
ah I feels good also we're back at the
plane crash that's cool this game is so
interesting I never ever enjoyed a
survival game this is a first for me
let's build our log cam in it I can't
carry anymore sticks that means we're
done with a log holder score high five
Oh what do we do with the log holder
know any crashed you know what I think I
think we're gonna wait with this game a
little bit until it gets a little
updated cuz I it's kind of not fun to
play with that's the case so yeah go
ahead look let me know watching let me
know if you want more uh maybe I'll do